so first of all I just want to say
congratulations you know when when I
have been trying to describe two people
what it was like to see moon is daydream
in an IMAX theater uh I I know you used
uh like a like an amusement park ride in
some ways but I I've also used the words
like being at Nasa for the launch of a
rocket
so how not just how did the project come
about but how did the way you were going
to make this entire film come about
well it started first of all thank you
so much for coming out this morning and
thank you Scott for hosting and it is a
true pleasure to share the stage with
the real stars of the film minus Paul
our sound team
um
uh the the film actually started with
sound uh you know we often talk about
seeing movies
um and don't often discuss hearing
movies and the premise for this started
in 2015 and I was interested in creating
something called the IMAX Music
Experience and the idea was to create a
series of films that were
um uh designed for IMAX theaters
non-linear non-biographical just kind of
the experience of an artist almost like
sort of extracting the juice from a
grape
um very much like as you said like theme
park ride and that was the kind of basis
of it and
um and then in 2016 David passed and I
had met with him eight years earlier
about another project I reached out to
his executor
um told him what I was interested in and
he said you know most people don't know
this but David saved everything
he was a bit of a hoarder and
um and he'd been working with an
archivist for the past 25 years but he
didn't he didn't want to participate in
a traditional Dock and he wasn't sure
what to do with all this material and so
um this kind of was this sort of perfect
um
simpatico situation uh they agreed to
give me
access to the entire archive and Final
Cut and um and then the film just
completely took changed uh
being a kind of just immersive
experience to I think something more
life-affirming which again was from
David you know I was taking all my
messaging and from from Bowie so David I
want to ask about about the
conversations that you first had knowing
like what the film was going to be what
the narrative structure was going to
take shape and a lot of that came
through his interviews but what were the
first conversations that that you all
had when it came to to digitizing the
footage to mashing uh some of the music
to really create the Sonic experience
that we just had
do you want to answer that John because
you Nina put well things together first
so uh well uh I think the first the
first conversation that we ever had uh
it was it was absolutely fascinating
because
um so we we said we're going to have a
spotting session of the film
normally when you have a spotting
session with a director you it's going
to take an afternoon uh you know that
everyone's going to talk a lot about the
opening of the movie
and as you get through the movie towards
the end people normally speed up and get
and we and okay we've got the we've got
the overall idea of this so the first
meeting with Brett uh we we were
obviously we were in London in the UK
and uh Brett Brett was here and after
two hours I remember looking at the uh
the the time code footage and we hadn't
actually hit the Five Minute Market of
the film uh we'd been talking about so
many uh ideas and and I thought to
myself at the time well yes of course
because Brett's been editing this
together for three years now
um he must have thought about a few
things along the way of those three
years and now obviously he wants to
discuss them everywhere so so yeah so
that that was the first of many many
spotting sessions we carried on through
the film in these sort of two-hour
chunks to discuss all the ideas that
could possibly be thought about
discussed and one of the one of the
wonderful things I I remember the moment
when uh Brett said to me he said he said
it said to us we were both he said um
well the thing is he said it doesn't
really matter about if if we decide that
that's what the sound is if we're going
to put that sound there because we've
decided that then that makes it right it
doesn't matter about the image we could
just decide what sounds we want to put
and put them where we were like and
because we've decided that that makes
them right I thought wow that's really
freeing from making a normal film
because normally you'd see a car you
think okay you need the sound of a car
but in this situation it's like we could
put the car wherever we want don't have
to even see a car we could just put it
where we like so that that was the first
uh kind of the first part of of I have
to say first watching the film uh
someone said to me what is it is it a
documentary is it a film yeah I was like
I I don't know and the only thing I
could think to say was it's kind of like
um
like a Bowie installation I said it it's
not really anything that that I've
worked on before uh and so so it was
very exciting it was a very exciting
project to be to be involved in yeah you
know when it came to framing the
narrative framing the The
forward-flowing Narrative of this film
how did you sift through Bowie's
interviews and what did you what stuck
out of you as you were developing that
narrative structure well I mean the
narrative structure was all put together
by Brett in terms of the interviews and
my role with that was to try and bring
some kind of
um consistency across his voice make
sure we could always understand what he
was saying
um and and make sure that it all played
and YouTube you are so you're hanging on
bows every word throughout this
documentary and obviously we had archive
material from many many different
um areas of uh his life and and
different times and it was uh it was
just quite a fair bit of work to try and
make sure that we could get his his
message across when did you start to say
say I I I think we got our nap we got
this we cracked it like when did you
start to look at each other and go all
right don't worry we've got our movie
here it is
well I I don't think obviously you never
reached that point where you think we've
got it's always a work in progress
everything is always a work in progress
but but I remember speaking to Dave and
saying Dave that there are some there's
going to be a lot of ideas in there that
we've discussed that we're not sure
about so we're going to leave them in
because because we're not sure we could
things could change things could move
around and so I think we ended up
sending a lot more ideas than than you
know just as a sort of a backup really
to give you some maneuverability but
actually I think quite a lot of the
ideas just stayed in and all played
together didn't they in many of the
scenes they really did we uh because
Brett and I went and worked together
well Paul was off working on the music
um Brett and I went through and just
spent days and days going through
effects and what would work here against
a guy track of music that we had
and uh so yeah I think
everything yeah kind of in there yeah
it's all over and and I think one of the
other things that we that we talked
about a lot as well was was how to
um sort of bring to life a lot of those
kind of concerts and the concert crowds
and and who are
um if you want to speak about yeah I
mean obviously all those performances it
was so crucial to try and make the
audience feel like they were
experiencing Bowie in those moments and
meeting him the first time and
transported in time if you like to Ziggy
Stardust walking on stage and so we did
an awful lot of listening through we had
such a fantastic library of material
there of all of his performances and how
the crowds responded to him at different
times throughout his career and we
really Drew on that in creating the
crowds to make sure that we were being
authentic to the different periods and
the different reactions of the fans
throughout his life last question is for
you Brett so in term terms of audience
response what has surprised you Brett
about the audience response to moonage
daydream well I what's really excited uh
surprised me is the acceptance of this
form
um that when from the time I started the
film I was deeply troubled and concerned
about
the fact that we were kind of existing
outside of the musical biographical
genre and genre is something I think we
take for granted
um it's because every film exists as
part of a genre and it's a covenant that
we have with the viewer that if you go
to a comedy it's a comedy and not a
tragedy if you go to see a music
documentary and it's about someone and
it just says David Bowie we only have
one way to interpret that which is
biographical
so from the very beginning it was like
how do we
set the audience up for the fact that
they're not going to be receiving
information that this is not fact-based
it's experiential
um and throughout the entire build up to
the launch all of our marketing all of
my press engagements were all geared
towards trying to set it
and when the film launched in 40
countries last two weeks ago
and I went to look at social media
it just seemed that people were taking
it at face value for what it is and not
what it isn't and that was really as a
someone who's committed their life to
theatrical non-fiction and bringing
movies bringing non-fiction into a
theatrical space to do that on a film
that's as kind of adventurous as this
film and to have the audience kind of
embrace that Adventure
um has been I think the the biggest
surprise uh for me personally and um
it's it's really been an amazing sort of
experience yeah absolutely so so Brett
David John and Nina thank you so much
for this incredible conversation and
ladies Gentlemen please do spread the
word about seeing moonage daydream in
theaters thank you everyone for being
here this afternoon thank you so much
thank you thank you Scott